hello and welcome to the agenda from
Strasbourg is time take a look at what's
happening next week in Brussels for
kicking things off at the Italian Prime
Minister Matteo Renzi made quite an
impression when he presented it to these
priorities at the plenary in Strasburg
at the beginning of July let's see if
his ministers can make an equally
dazzling impression back in Brussels
they'll be doing the rounds of
committees all day on Tuesday presenting
their priorities and expectations
hopefully we won't be seeing boredom if
he's taking selfies at sense meeting
Venice forms the backdrop for the lux
prize a special press conference will
take place at the Venice Film Festival
to whittle down a short list from 10 to
three films could the French entry
girlhood do well or how about the
spanish movie about love and struggle
beautiful youth find out more on tuesday
as 10 become 3 on the menu today we'll
have vegetables fruit and milk well
that's if you're of a school going age
the decades now a program has been in
place to make sure kids get their
essential nutrients at school and all
that food is provided from new farms on
Wednesday the Commission will stop by
the Agriculture Committee to kick off
the revision of the existing legislation
and a quick mention of trade commission
ocala book on tuesday he will be at the
trade committee meeting and it's
expected that your briefing pees on the
latest round of negotiations on the
eu-us trade deal and that's all we have
for this agenda from the beautiful
rooftop of the strasburg plenary take
care and enjoy the week